so i am uncomfortable with this concept
of work-life balance
um because balance is achieved with two
opposing forces
and why should work and life be in
opposition right
and uh i i don't think there's if you
don't have work life balance if you're
struggling to find work-life balance
no amount of yoga will fix that right
um taking off an extra week of vacation
and by the way vacation means you're not
working on the beach that's just
telecommuting from a beach
um um but i believe
in in uh that the
that you're able to build a life where
work
and personal life become
uh not only do you say interchangeable
but smooth and what i mean by that is
they're not necessarily confined by
hours in a day
but rather where i choose to give effort
so for example if it's four o'clock in
the afternoon
technically part of the work day and
you're hankering for a run because it's
a day like this
you go for a run like that's you know
and one of the things one of the
mistakes that i've made
was treating things that are important
to my mind
my body my spirit as stub something that
i'm supposed
only supposed to do off hours or on
weekends
but just like i can't decide when i have
an idea
sometimes it's on saturday and sometimes
it's in the evening i also can't decide
when i need a break
sometimes it's something i feel that's
something i plan for and so
we've gotten really good it's imperfect
you know sometimes responsibility takes
precedence but we've gotten really good
in our little company
that if somebody wants to take an
afternoon to be with their kids
they put in their calendar with my kids
a long time ago
i used to have when i when i had um a
different form of a business before all
of this stuff
we used to have things called duvet days
which i i
i remember we had like five duvet days a
year or something and a do they day was
you wake up in the morning you just
don't want to come to work
you're totally healthy or it's a
beautiful day and i just would rather go
to the beach
so you'd call up and leave a message at
eight o'clock in the morning or seven
o'clock and we'll be like hey i'm taking
a duvet day i'll see you tomorrow
and no one would bother you right and
people like
that's amazing that you do that sign i'm
like people are doing that anyway it's
called
hey i think i have a 24-hour bug i'm
going to be at work today and they go to
the beach
so just call it out um you know
schedule time at the gym in the middle
of the day if that's when you like
working out
and i just found the the more seamless
that we can make
work in life um the more we start to
enjoy
both more because they're not they're
not opposing